[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is
primarily a question and
answer show.
So if any of you out there would
like to ask questions.
JEREMY WALKER: Hi.
Welcome to the YouTube
Developers Live.
We have a great show today.
We have some guests here.
My name's Jeremy.
We have Jarek, of course.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Hi, guys.
JEREMY WALKER: And
we're both on the
Developer Advocate team.
And we also have Jeff
on the line.
But I'm really excited.
We have some people
from GoAnimate.
We have Gary.
GARY LIPKOWITZ: Yes.
Hi, I'm Gary Lipkowitz.
I'm with GoAnimate.
JEREMY WALKER: And then we
have Alvin, who actually
started up the whole company.
And then we also have Ben on
the line who's one of the
developers for GoAnimate.
BEN NG: Hi, everyone.
JEREMY WALKER: And then I
mentioned Jeff earlier, who's
also one of the Google
Developer advocates.
JEFF: Hi, guys.
JEREMY WALKER: Hi, Jeff.
How's life in New York?
JEFF: Pretty good.
Trying a new setup here today,
so bear with any technical
difficulties that we have
with the audio or video.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: You
have some fancy
new digs over there.
JEFF: Yes.
We have a nice lush New York
City background as you can see
behind me with the YouTube logo
over everyone's shoulder.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: But you seem
to be moving in slow motion.
Are you kicking it
in New York City?
I thought New Yorkers are
uptight, and they move very
fast and everything.
So what's up with that?
JEFF: Yeah.
We need to get a data center
out in New York, I guess.
It's just obviously taking a lot
of time to send my video
signal out to you guys
in Mountain View.
So sorry about that.
We should get that technical
stuff worked out for next
week's broadcast.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
Your voice sounds
fine, though.
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah.
And the background's
awesome, too.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: No
problem there.
So Alvin and Ben are joining
us from Hong Kong.
What time is it there
right now?
ALVIN HUNG: It's actually 1:00
AM in Hong Kong right now
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Wow.
You guys work really hard.
Great.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
Well, I'm really excited.
So GoAnimate, I'm going to let
you guys talk a little bit
about your company and
how you got started.
But I'm really excited
because I love
animation, and I love anime.
And I know we're going
to talk a little
bit about that today--
GARY LIPKOWITZ: Absolutely.
JEREMY WALKER: --and how you
guys are expanding into that
for your users.
But why don't you guys
get started?
Just talk a little bit why you
got started and the whole
story behind GoAnimate.
GARY LIPKOWITZ: Sure.
We'll let Alvin do that since
he's the founder.
He knows the origins the best.
ALVIN HUNG: So a few years ago,
I was trying to turn the
story in my head into a
video, and it was very
difficult to do.
I didn't want to hire actors,
and I didn't have any camera
equipment with me.
And if I wanted to create an
animation, I would need to
draw very well.
But I don't know how to draw.
And so basically back then,
I was completely stuck.
I had this really funny story
in my head, but I just
couldn't turn it into a video.
And that was very frustrating.
And I thought, there must be a
lot of people out there with
great ideas who want to express
those ideas as video.
It can't be that hard.
And that's why I founded
GoAnimate as a simple website,
a simple way for everyone to
create videos and express
themselves.
JEREMY WALKER: Awesome.
Can you tell us a little bit
about how your system is
implemented?
ALVIN HUNG: It's fairly
simple, actually.
All our client-side
applications
are done using Flash.
On the server side, we are
running on a LAN stack, so
basically Linux, Apache,
MySQL, and PHP.
And the whole thing we are using
Amazon Web Services.
So everything is basically
in the cloud.
JEREMY WALKER: Oh,
that's great.
Can you talk a little bit about
converting these Flash
animations into video and what
kind of time it takes and a
little bit more about that?
ALVIN HUNG: So we basically have
a server file where we
have these Windows machines
running 24 hours a day.
And depending on demand at any
moment in time, we will fire
up new servers or tier
down useless ones.
And we basically dynamically
allocate capacity depending on
how much traffic we have.
On the average, it takes between
5 to 10 minutes for a
video to convert,
so fairly fast.
JEREMY WALKER: Oh, wow.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And
you actually render
frames frame by frame?
What's the actual process?
Because the animations are
actually executed in the
Flash, right?
We don't actually in
just Flash for--
at YouTube, we need some sort
of encoded video stream.
So was that kind of the most
challenging part of the
integration?
What did you guys end up doing
about that, and how
difficult was that?
ALVIN HUNG: The very cool thing
about using Flash is
that when people are composing
their video, they can
instantly preview what
they have done.
It doesn't go through
a rendering process.
And so that instant feedback
and gratification
is extremely important.
As to how we actually get all
the Flash stuff into video
format, that's black magic.
So we'll review that later on.
But yeah, there's some pretty
cool stuff going on.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah, yeah.
Just trying, you know,
to see if we can get
something from you.
But it sounds like it's your
competitive advantage, which
is actually very neat.
I played with the tool, and
it works really well.
So what about character
development?
You guys have a very wide
range of characters.
How do you decide what is hot
and what should be made
available to your users?
How does the process work?
ALVIN HUNG: We get feedback
from a variety of places.
We ask for our users'
feedback.
We basically ask on the forums
what kind of characters would
enable them to be
more creative.
What kind of characters
would let them
express themselves better?
We do a lot of data mining.
We look into our database, and
we study what kind of behavior
people are displaying.
And we basically go online, and
we scout the web and look
for file content.
What kind of content
is getting filed at
any moment in time?
What kind of styling
do people like?
And we take this feedback
together, and we basically
brainstorm and try to find
directions that will satisfy
some aspects of these demand.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I see.
Cool.
Maybe we should take a look at
a quick demo and then ask you
some more questions so people
who are not familiar with
GoAnimate can get a basic
idea of how it works.
ALVIN HUNG: Certainly.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
Can we do that?
GARY LIPKOWITZ: We can.
We've been specially trained.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
Let's go for it.
GARY LIPKOWITZ: I had some
queued up for the demo.
So actually I'm going
to go off script.
I'll show you a real short
one because it's topical.
And this is also an old internet
meme, so all the
older guys out there will--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
MALE SPEAKER: Here one
should see in Wasabi.
JOE BIDEN: Wasabi.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, wasabi.
MALE SPEAKER: Wasabi, abi.
MALE SPEAKER: Wasabi.
JOE BIDEN: Wasaaaaaabi.
JOE BIDEN: Wasabi.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Wasaaaaaabi.
MALE SPEAKER: Wasabi.
[ALL SPEAKING]
Wasabi, Wasaaabi, Wasabi,
Oh, ah, aaaah, Oh, ah.
MALE SPEAKER: Wasabi.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
GARY LIPKOWITZ: So that
one's featuring--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Does that
conclude the demo?
GARY LIPKOWITZ: That does
not conclude the demo.
That was off-script.
That was an extra
special bonus.
But we thought the election's
making headlines again.
We'd show off the election
characters one more time.
Everybody likes to see Joe
Biden in a bar, as
far as I can tell.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah,
yeah, yeah.
So how does the process work?
Can you walk through
the actual process
of creating an animation?
GARY LIPKOWITZ: Sure.
You'd log into YouTube Create
and then select GoAnimate.
You'd end up on a homepage
that's divided into quick
video makers and full
video makers.
But for the purpose of today, I
think we'll just look at the
full video makers.
The quick video maker's a very
structured solution.
You would, just using only left
and right arrow, pick
some characters, pick a
background, type or record
some lines of dialogue,
and press Play.
But I think this will be more
interesting for the audience.
So I would click on one of these
Make a Movie buttons,
and that would lead
me to what we call
the Studio in aggregate.
And some key parts here, there's
a pull-down menu that
shows some of the creative
options available.
These two video makers are
behind the Business paywall.
If we were in the Consumer
section, there would be more
than a dozen video makers
or creative
themes to choose from.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So this is--
you could create a version of
the application which has a
limited set of characters?
Is that what you mean?
GARY LIPKOWITZ: No.
We wanted to show some
of the new stuff.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: OK.
GARY LIPKOWITZ: I could go out
and come back in and load the
studio with the consumer video
makers, and you would still
have more than a dozen.
Everything is available.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So Consumer
is the version that's
available for free?
Or is it premium?
GARY LIPKOWITZ: It's premium.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Premium.
GARY LIPKOWITZ: Correct.
And this part up here, this grey
part on the left, we call
this the tray.
And you'll see it's
multi-tabbed.
And this is where all of the
assets are, assets being
Characters, Backgrounds, Props,
Music, Visual Effects.
And this one here, as
you can probably
guess, is the Text tool.
This area is called the stage,
and this is the frame of your
video that you're creating.
Down here is the timeline.
And you can see your picture
arranged in the timeline as
well as multiple audio tracks.
Let's start by changing
the background.
This crumpled paper is good.
Let me do one a little
more woody themed.
Everything is point and
click, drag and drop.
So all I do is drag it in,
and it takes over.
If there were multiple elements
on this background,
like a forest scene with lots
of trees and rocks and
boulders and sunshine, in many
cases all of those elements
are layered and individually
controllable, so you can make
them bigger, smaller,
or delete them.
And of course, we want
some characters.
So again, you just drag
them in the screen.
I want him on the left,
so I want him to
face the other way.
I can flip him.
If we were multilayered, I can
move him backward and forward.
And if I decide I don't
want him, I can
just get rid of him.
So you know, with this guy, I
want a little more spiky hair.
Once I've selected
a character, I
can give him actions.
I can--
sorry, double click there.
I can give him facial
expressions.
I can give him basic sliding
movements, or I can give him
more advanced entrances
and exits.
So some of these tools work a
little bit like what your
expectations are
for PowerPoint.
I choose Enter or Exit, timed
with the previous scene or put
a little delay on it, and then
there's many choices.
So maybe I just want
him to fade in.
I can adjust the timing
if I want.
And then if I click Preview,
basically we'd see the one and
only scene.
We'll watch this guy fade in.
JEREMY WALKER: Cool.
GARY LIPKOWITZ: And then
I would say, OK.
I'm happy with the way
it's starting.
I'm going to go back and
add more scenes or more
characters.
So again, I just want the
blue-haired guy here.
I just drag him in.
If I want him to be gigantic,
if I want him to be tiny and
live in the corner or sit
on his shoulder, I
can do all of that.
I think I need a prop
to work with.
I would go in this menu.
He looks like a lounge
singer to me.
I'll put a microphone in here.
In some cases, although probably
not in this video
maker, you can drag the props
onto the characters.
They'll hold it with
their hand.
Then you'll get another
menu controlling what
they do with it.
In this case, I think I
want the microphone--
if I could operate the
mouse better--
to be gigantic and
live over here.
I'm not very good at design,
as you can tell.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Well, you're
doing better than--
GARY LIPKOWITZ: And then maybe
we wanted to add text.
I think this one's
self-explanatory, just
double-click.
Then if we wanted to change a
text color, we can do that
with a single click.
Justify the text differently,
very easy.
It's all designed to
work intuitively.
Our brand promises--
you wouldn't need to learn how
to draw or program in order to
make a compelling animation
with this.
You can just unleash your
inner director.
I can show you what this theme
looks like in a video.
If you guys have another minute,
we'll show what it all
looks like when something's
who's good at
design puts it together.
JEREMY WALKER: Sure.
Bring it on.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
NARRATOR: Guys, when the Supreme
Being was handing out
brains, were you out to lunch?
When you try to do math, does
it hurt a whole bunch?
That's because you're
dumb, you meathead.
This can be a big, big problem,
you know, for life.
But not anymore.
Thinking Cap is a revolutionary
hat designed for
dumb guys like you.
Just put it on and get
smarter immediately.
How much smarter?
10 points smarter.
That's how much.
That's a lot.
How does it work?
It's got this antenna on top.
And when smart guys walk by, it
sucks the brain power right
out of them.
Best part?
It stores the smarts inside the
hat, so you don't have to
hang around smart guys
all the time.
Because that would be
freaking boring.
What's the catch?
You got to shave your head
or it doesn't work.
But hey, you're going to be
wearing the hat, so who cares?
Thinking Cap, the only way you
could be dumber is if you
didn't buy it.
Now with all 32 NFL logos.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
GARY LIPKOWITZ: So one thing
that video illustrates is the
characters and the props and
text tool all working together
to tell the story.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: One thing
I noticed, there was
an image of a hand--
GARY LIPKOWITZ: Yeah.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: --at some
point in the video.
Is that something that
you can introduce?
Can you take a photo and
mix it in to the video?
GARY LIPKOWITZ: That's a
built-in transition.
That's one of our hand wipes.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Oh,
I see, I see.
GARY LIPKOWITZ: And they're
real popular now in demo
videos, so we've kind
of built that in.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So it's a meme
now, like the hand wipe.
GARY LIPKOWITZ: Yeah.
And as Alvin was saying earlier,
we try to anticipate
what people want in
their videos.
And then we go out and add
that to the product.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I see.
GARY LIPKOWITZ: And that was
something we'd seen in a lot
of popular demo videos, so we
thought, hey, we need to offer
this to our users.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I see.
So I have a question, a
couple of questions.
Alvin, we mentioned you guys
are out in Hong Kong.
What prompted you to start
your business there?
ALVIN HUNG: Oh, I got married
in Hong Kong.
And between going back to
Silicon Valley and my family
and my wife here, I thought
it would be easier to be
based in Hong Kong.
So therefore, I just
started here.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Oh, wow.
How's the entrepreneur community
out in Hong Kong?
Do you find a lot of people
doing video-related work?
Or are you kind of the
only one out there?
ALVIN HUNG: There's a good
group of people here, but
definitely not as vibrant
as Silicon Valley.
Being able to be based in the
Bay Area definitely has become
more advantageous than in Hong
Kong in that aspect.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I see.
Well, you can always join a
Hangout at 1:00 AM in the
morning, you know?
ALVIN HUNG: Exactly.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
Hey, Ben, you've been quiet.
We wanted to check with you to
see, from an implementation
standpoint, were there any
challenges that you have
encountered that you didn't
anticipate while
building the system?
And then the question that we
always like to ask also is how
is the user authentication
and authorization
handled in the system?
Because you allow uploads into
users' YouTube accounts.
So can you tell us a little
bit more about the flow?
BEN NG: In the YouTube
application for user
authentication, we make use
of OpenID and OAuth.
And basically it's
not really hard.
And we implemented this in
one working day only.
It's not really difficult.
Yeah, I'm nervous.
Sorry.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Don't worry.
There's only 1,000 people
watching you right now.
BEN NG: And it's not really
difficult because Google
provides enough documentation.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Right, yeah.
We always get compliments about
the user documentation.
I think we should bring our tech
writer Andy into the room
one of these days and ask him
questions about his secret
sauce, just like I was trying
to extract that information
from Alvin a little earlier.
So anything that surprised
you while you were
building the solution?
We always like to ask people if
there's anything as far as
the implementation or the user
behavior or stuff that you
just didn't expect and
it blew your mind.
BEN NG: At first we always see
some users ask us why they
cannot upload their videos
because they haven't created a
channel in YouTube, but
they log in with
their Google account.
And we found this out later.
And it's somehow a bit hidden
when we've tried to implement
the features at first.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah, yeah.
That part is a little
tricky, I think.
For folks who are not familiar
with how the Google account
support works for YouTube is
we introduced support for
Google accounts a while back
where if you have a Google
account but you don't have a
YouTube channel, you can still
log into YouTube.
And then there's only a subset
of functionality that we make
available with the setup.
There's actually a blog post
up on the API blog at
youtube.com, and it goes into
some more detail about what
you can do to remedy
this situation.
So, in fact, there is an API
that allows you to help a user
create a channel in that
situation so they can actually--
If they don't have a YouTube
channel, they cannot upload
videos to YouTube.
But with the API, you can
actually create it on their
behalf, and then they will
be able to upload it.
And the situation can actually
be determined by
using the API as well.
So we have what's called an
incomplete profile that is
returned through the API in
a situation like that one.
Yeah, but that's something
that we've heard before.
It's good feedback.
Yeah.
Anything good that happened?
BEN NG: Yeah.
Luckily, recently we did
them at [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah, it's much better now.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
So another question, Alvin, you
guys are very much heavy
into Flash and web.
And I was just curious to see
what do you think about how
things are going on the
mobile side of things?
Do you think people will be
trying to create similar
animations on their smartphones
or tablets?
And what are you going
to do about that?
ALVIN HUNG: We're actively
looking into deploying our
applications for the
mobile experience.
But the trick is that the use
cases and the phone factor is
so different.
So we cannot just straight
away port our existing
applications to those devices.
What we're doing right now
is to rearchitect our
functionalities and make them in
such a way that it's really
fitting for the mobile user.
Mobile is here to stay.
Mobile is the new phenomenon.
So, therefore, for sure that's
a platform that we are
actively developing for.
And we are thinking about
what are the best
ways to achieve that.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
And then are you thinking
about HTML5 as well?
Because that's another thing
that I wonder about.
You see a lot of Flash
apps looking actively
at the HTML5 space.
Do you think what you have
done, would that even be
possible from your perspective
with HTML5?
Or is it still not
quite there yet?
ALVIN HUNG: HTML5 is not
really ready for us yet
because Flash actually is a
great tool set that enables
our artists to create a lot of
assets very efficiently.
In order to make it work for
HTML5, we have to have that
tool set be ready for
HTML5 as well.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I see.
ALVIN HUNG: To overcome that,
what we're doing now is to
look into porting assets
created using the Flash
toolkit but have it
be readable and
renderable by HTML5.
So we're trying to bridge
that right now.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I see.
Interesting.
So it's doesn't seem like it's
the inherent technology issue,
but rather on the creative side
some of the tools are not
quite there yet to support
an HTML5 application.
Interesting.
ALVIN HUNG: Right, right.
What we're thinking is that it
may be actually more efficient
to develop for natively on the
mobile devices, so basically
using Apple Objective-C directly
to create native
applications as opposed to using
HTML5 to service those
apps, which is much
more efficient.
And they have the tool
set ready for us.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Sure, sure.
So you've been coding
Objective-C and Java on this
site instead of Flash lately?
ALVIN HUNG: We are looking into
doing stuff like that.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: How's
the learning curve?
ALVIN HUNG: My engineers,
ask them.
They're fine.
Yeah.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah, they
don't sleep, right?
It's 1:00 AM, and you
guys are still up.
So, obviously, you
guys can do it.
JEREMY WALKER: I had
a couple questions.
You guys are adding
a couple more
characters, Japanese influence.
I'm just curious where you're
getting your ideas on those.
Are they anime?
Are they manga?
GARY LIPKOWITZ: Those two
are largely the same.
But I think a lot of our team
grew up really interested in
anime and manga and so have
these images in their head and
follow the new ones
coming out.
So I think it was not a big
ask to ask them to create
anime-looking characters.
Do you want to see the
anime video maker?
JEREMY WALKER: Sure.
GARY LIPKOWITZ: Do you want me
to just quickly show you some
characters?
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah, that
would be great.
Probably just for me, I guess.
GARY LIPKOWITZ: We have
ninja and regular.
Let's see.
Actually, I have to do
this separately.
While that's loading,
let's see.
Alvin, did you have anything
else to add on
the origin of anime?
ALVIN HUNG: It's probably the
most exciting project that
I've seen our creators
jumping on.
Like Gary said, they all
grew up watching anime.
And so being able to create
these dream characters that
they want to draw themselves
anyway is a lot of fun.
So yeah, totally.
GARY LIPKOWITZ: And it goes
without saying that ninjas are
really cool.
Again, just to show the ease of
swapping in a background.
Or I can show you some of the--
we were talking about
you can remove individual
items.
So there I just made
a boulder go away.
And now I decided I want to
change the whole background.
And then let's see, if we wanted
some characters to be
in here, this guy looks
pretty tough.
But let's make him tiny and have
him stand on the table
because that's always cool.
And let's have her be gigantic
and get ready to beat him up.
Sorry, very bad with
the mouse.
Again, I don't know that you'd
really scale them like this.
I just want to show
you how easy it is
to manipulate things.
I want this thing to go away.
I can move the table.
Now he's levitating in space
because he's a ninja fairy
from the mountains.
I'll just keep dragging all
the characters in there.
I think that's what people
want to see the most.
This girl's pretty cool.
And then this is your typical
I'm wearing my black outfit.
Sorry, you must go away.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: We
have to pay now?
GARY LIPKOWITZ: Yes.
JEREMY WALKER: Is that
like a gopher?
GARY LIPKOWITZ: You guys
pick up so fast.
I love coming here.
So this is your typical
black-clad ninja who sneaks
into the camp at night, and
nobody notices him and is
silent like the wind, and
then can draw his sword
in 1/100 of a second.
But I didn't use to
watch this stuff.
I'm just speculating that
he could do that.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Well, you're
pretty good at improvisation
if you didn't watch.
I'll tell you that.
GARY LIPKOWITZ: Yeah.
OK.
Anything else you want to see?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: This
is pretty cool.
Is this already out
there released?
GARY LIPKOWITZ: Oh, yeah.
This is live.
We just accessed it from
YouTube Create.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Oh, great.
GARY LIPKOWITZ: And there's
the regular anime them.
And there it is, the
ninja anime.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
Maybe one closing question
for you, Alvin.
So we've been playing around
with this, and it seems like a
great consumer tool.
You mentioned there is a
business version of it.
So what do businesses
do with this?
ALVIN HUNG: Actually, there are
a lot of startups using us
to create demo videos.
Sorry, I didn't see
the demo video.
What was that?
Thinking Cap?
GARY LIPKOWITZ: Oh, yeah.
We showed Thinking Cap.
ALVIN HUNG: OK.
So, yeah, Thinking Cap is
actually a great example of
what a typical demo video would
be like, being able to
mix animations with dynamic
text and stuff like that.
There are also a lot of schools
using GoAnimate,
basically educators engaging
students in the classroom.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
GARY LIPKOWITZ: And we don't
need to show it now because
it's more than two minutes
long, but if you go to
goanimate.com/business, there's
a business demo video
that kind of walks through some
of the use cases that a
business user would want
to use GoAnimate for.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
Well, thank you very much for
joining us this late.
I guess it's 1:30
AM in Hong Kong.
Time to hit the bars,
I suppose.
GARY LIPKOWITZ: The
anime bars.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Anime bars.
Again, thank you very much.
And I think we will now
transition over to Jeff.
Jeff was going to talk about
API quotas and how we can
avoid them.
So over to you, Jeff.
JEFF: Cool.
Thanks, guys.
That was really neat watching
all the GoAnimate stuff.
I want to make sure that
everybody can hear me, OK?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah,
we can hear you fine.
JEFF: OK.
And apologies in advance.
I think my video is probably
going to be a
little messed up.
And the frame rate, there's
going to be some new putting
out from here.
It isn't super high, so maybe I
can try to pretend like I'm
always in motion or something,
or get a shot of me talking,
and that'll be always
on the screen.
So I'm here talking, even
if you don't see me.
OK.
So for those of you who don't
frequent our YouTube API
developer forums, I post
there quite a bit.
And one of the questions that
we get very frequently are
things related to YouTube API
quota system and specifically
the YouTube data API
quota system.
I've tried to put together some
resources that I tend to
just send out to people whenever
questions come up.
And we have two blog posts in
particular that are kind of
related to quota and
specifically quota with uploads.
And one of them is just a
general quota blog post.
It's on our YouTube API blog.
It's entitled "Best Practices
for Avoiding Quota Issues."
If you happen to be following
along on Google+ and you're
following the YouTube for
developers Google+ account,
you can see that I've shared the
links to these blog posts
there, so you guys can go and
reference them later.
But there's that one blog post
that just talks about general
quota issues, and there's
another that talks about best
practices for soliciting
uploads
from your site's community.
And I want to provide a recap
of both of those and some
general quota best practices for
folks who might not have
seen those blog posts before.
So the first thing that you
really need to make sure is
that you're actually
encountering a quota issue.
Because there are a few other
types of problems that could
sometimes come up with using the
YouTube API, things about
authentication or--
I don't know- just bad passing
and bad parameters when you're
making your requests.
And just because you're getting
an error back from the
YouTube data API doesn't mean
you're actually running into a
quota error.
So there's a very specific way
of determining whether you're
getting a quota error or not.
And that's by taking a look at
that HTTP response body that
you get back from
every request.
We have a policy of always
sending back an HTTP response.
We don't just ignore your
requests if you start sending
us too many requests or
anything like that.
We'll always let
you know what's
going on with a response.
So checking that response body
is always very important.
If you happen to be using
a client library--
I know a lot of folks use client
libraries when they're
developing in C API.
Usually whenever we return an
error response from the
YouTube data API, the client
library will automatically
deserialize that error
response and raise an
exception on your behalf.
So basically, the quota errors
might manifest themselves as
exceptions that your application
may or may not
already be handling.
But you could always take a look
at the exception and take
a look at the details of the
exception and see exactly what
the underlying cause
of the error is.
So that's a little specific to
which library you're using.
I'm just going to talk on the
HTTP protocol level and tell
you what the response looks
like in that case.
And hopefully you guys can
mentally translate that to
what will actually be returned
from a client library.
So what you will get back on the
HTTP level when there's a
quota error is an HTTP
403 response.
403 is the response code.
And the response body will
include some specific text in
it saying that the domain of the
error is YT quota and the
error code is too many
recent calls.
So that's how you know that
you're getting a quota error.
If you get any other type of
error back, we're certainly
happy to help you try
to debug that.
And you can post about it in the
Google group, and we'll do
what we can to assist.
But you're not getting a quota
error unless you see that.
So that's the first
thing to verify.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah.
One thing to add is I think we
quite frequently hear from
developers who tell us that they
are getting quota errors.
But actually, unless that
element is present in the HTTP
response to many recent
calls, it is not
actually a quota error.
So I wanted just to stress that
this is kind of the first
thing to check before
you assume you're
having quota issues.
JEFF: Absolutely.
So the other thing that comes
up when people start talking
about the quota system, and
normally I'll say, hey, you
know you're running
into quota errors.
Take a look at this.
They'll say, OK, great.
So tell me exactly how many
calls I can make with the API
before I start getting
back quota errors.
And I can understand the desire
to have some hard
limits and to know exactly
what you could do.
We don't share, really, too
many details about the
underlying numbers used in the
quota system publicly for a
couple of reasons.
And I'm hopefully not going to
end up giving away anything
today in this GDL also.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
Come on, Jeff.
No leaks day to day?
What's wrong with you?
JEFF: You know what?
I would prefer not
to, let's say.
So I don't think I'm going to
be sharing anything too
scandalous here.
But just basically, first of
all, we don't want to give out
specific numbers because
obviously that does open the
door a little bit more
towards abuse.
The point is people should not
be sending absolutely as much
traffic as they can
to the API.
They should be sending
absolutely as much traffic as
they legitimately need to.
So if you do need to post a
whole bunch of new videos,
upload a whole bunch of new
videos to an account, I'm not
going to tell you
not to do that.
But I'm going to tell you
you shouldn't try to
reverse-engineer the quota
system to figure out the exact
limit of the number of videos
that you can send before you
get a quota error.
You should just try to send
as many as you can.
And then we'll talk about in
a few minutes the ways you
should gracefully deal
with quota errors.
So yes.
My general advice is you really
shouldn't have to know
the exact limits.
You should code defensively
around them and adjust
gracefully when you do encounter
a quota error.
But just to give you a little
peek behind the curtain-- and
I mentioned this in the
blog post a bit, too--
that we don't just have
a single number
for the quota system.
It's not just like you can make
10 calls per minute and
then you start getting
quota errors.
The quota system that we're
using right now for the
Version 1, Version 2 of the data
API is actually really,
really nuanced and was designed
in order to take into
account the overall costs
of different operations.
And we allude to this again.
In blog posts, we'll learn a bit
about how read operations
are a little bit cheaper
on our system.
And you could tend to make a few
more read operations than
you can write operations or
update operations, and this is
intentional.
So there isn't a
single number.
There might be like, you know,
if you say, I'm trying to get
videos, and I'm doing a read
operation to get videos.
Yes, there is a number of those
that you could do per
minute before you encounter
quota error.
But assuming you're writing an
application that does a whole
bunch of different types of API
interactions, where you're
doing some reads, you're doing
some writes, you're doing a
bunch of different things,
there's no one magic number.
So that's kind of the other
misconception or thing that's
not entirely obvious about
the system that I
wanted to make clear.
If you look at the blog post
that I referenced, the "Best
Practices for Avoiding Quota
Issues" blog post, you'll
notice that there's one piece of
specific information that I
really want to highlight.
And this, in many cases, will
solve quota issues that just
normal applications
would have.
And that's that you should
always use a developer key
when you're making a request
against the API.
There's certain operations that
require a developer key.
Specifically anything that does
a write or an update or a
delete of a resource on YouTube
requires a developer
key already.
So if you're making those types
of calls, chances are
you already are using
a developer key.
Otherwise, you'd have bigger
problems than quota issues.
But a lot of people
don't know that.
For read operations, you could
also include a developer key.
And while it's optional, the way
the quota system works, we
actually do reward users for
including a developer key by
giving them a bit more than
the default quota.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
Yeah, in fact.
I just wanted to add, just
speaking of our experience,
quite frequently we hear back
from developers asking for
help with the quota.
And we point out the blog post
about quota best practices,
which states please include
developer key.
They do that and their
problems go away.
So I think for those people
that are watching us today
live or on video, this is
a little bonus for you.
If you include the developer key
for operations that don't
actually require it, you will
automatically be granted more
quota because YouTube loves
developers, and that's pretty
much how it goes.
Right, Jeff?
JEFF: Yeah.
Yeah, the actual rationale
behind giving a little bit
more quota to developer key,
it's not completely anonymous
traffic at that point.
You do have to register
for a developer key.
You have to sign in with
your Google account.
The developer of the application
needs to do this,
not your users.
But once you register, at least
we know something about
you if we happen to detect that
your traffic is really
causing trouble for us for some
reason, not that that
would happen.
We have some way of reaching
out to you.
So it just assigns a little
bit more, I guess, way of
tracing things back to you.
And in return, we'll grant you
some additional quota.
So that's, as Jarek said, kind
of the easiest way to resolve
most quota issues that
people run into.
So the blog post, again, I keep
referring back to has
some guidelines for what you
should do if you encounter a
quota issue.
And on the blog post it actually
says you should take
about 10 minutes and pause and
don't send anymore traffic
after receiving a quota issue.
That's true.
That's something that will, in
many cases, give enough time
for our quota system to reset.
And at that point you should be
able to start sending most
types of traffic again.
But it's not necessarily the
most optimal thing if you're
really trying optimize
for the amount of API
calls you can make.
And again, this is because
you're making
legitimate API calls.
We really don't want to
encourage people to do
anything too spammy or
anything like that.
But we understand that there
are applications out there
that legitimately need to work
within our quota limits and
might be bumping up
against them.
So if you wanted to be a little
bit more flexible than
just doing a blanket wait 10
minutes, don't send any
traffic and then start back
up again, you could try an
incremental backoff, or an
exponential backoff, I guess,
in this case.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: That's
even stronger, Jeff.
Yeah, let's go exponential,
man.
JEFF: Let's go a power
series backoff maybe.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right.
JEFF: No.
Let's keep it exponential,
let's say.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right.
JEFF: Let's say that in this
case you will pause for a
certain fixed amount of
time to begin with.
And if I were to throw out
some numbers here-- and
there's no exact
right number--
let's say 30 seconds might be
your initial pause, and you
could do it 15 seconds as your
initial pause if you
really wanted to.
We're not going to really
penalize you for trying to
send traffic again
too quickly.
So don't worry that
you're specifying
something way too low.
But at the same time, you don't
want to keep hammering
our servers, because
it's wasting
bandwidth on your side.
It's wasting bandwidth
on our side.
So let's say you wait 30
seconds initially.
You try sending your
traffic again.
If you're still getting back the
same type of quota error,
then you double the amount
of time that you wait.
You wait a minute in between
that and your next call.
You try again after a minute,
still get a quota error, you
can double again, and you
wait two minutes.
And this just gives you a
really flexible system.
You usually do want to put an
upper cap on the amount of
time that you wait.
You might want say eight minutes
is your upper cap, or
16 minutes is your upper cap.
And once you reach that, you
could either just give up
entirely, or you could, instead
of multiplying by two
each time, just always wait 16
minutes in between times.
And this is definitely a very
robust way of dealing with
quota errors.
And if you're looking to
maximize the amount of class
you can make again, this will
probably end up being a lot
more beneficial than just
waiting 10 minutes.
So it's a little bit hard to
explain on a blog post.
We kind of just stuck with the
10 minutes in that blog post
as the recommendation.
But a little benefit for folks
who are watching along and
pick up something new.
We can't just regurgitate
things from the
blog all the time.
We want to provide some new
information to folks.
So another thing related to
quota that we hear a lot is--
actually, folks aren't even
really aware of the fact that
this is related to quota--
the number of uploads you could
have in a given account.
So for a long time, the YouTube
API would only allow
2,000 videos in a
given account.
And we had this documented, and
if you tried to upload a
new video using the API, after
the account had its 2,000th
video, for a while it would
just completely fail.
Then we relaxed it a little bit
and said I think you could
upload 50 new videos
in a given day once
you reach 2,000 videos.
And all this was before our,
let's say, newer quota system
rolled out.
And once we had this more
flexible quota system I'm
talking about, we just said, OK,
instead of imposing this
arbitrary cap of 2,000 videos,
at which point we have this
other arbitrary cap of 50 new
videos per day, let's let the
quota system handle everything
related to uploads and let the
quota system protect from
potential abuse.
We obviously still do not want
people to upload hundreds and
hundreds of spammy videos
into their accounts
programmatically, so we do
need some protection.
But the quota system is flexible
enough to provide
that protection.
So if you'll check our online
Frequently Asked Questions and
everything, we've completely
scrubbed all reference to
2,000 videos per account.
And I know we still get
questions about that.
I think this has kind of entered
into lore where people
think there's still this
2,000-video limit.
That's no longer in place.
And it's the quota system that
impacts who could upload and
whether an upload will
succeed or not.
So there's a separate blog post
that I referenced and I
have the link to on the Google+
page for YouTube for
developers that talks about
"Best Practices for Soliciting
Uploads from Your Site's
Community." I call it your
site, but this could
be a website.
It might even be an offline
application.
Just anytime when you're kind
of running an online
community, and you want to
solicit videos, and you want
your users to be able to respond
to a question or just
interact or share things
in some way via video.
So we certainly want
to encourage that
use case within YouTube.
That's obviously a great thing
that we could facilitate.
But it's a little problematic in
the way that most people by
default try to go about
doing this.
And that's by hard coding in the
credentials for one master
account somewhere and then
telling people, hey, everybody
can just upload videos
using the API into
this one master account.
So there's a couple of reasons
why it's problematic.
First from the policy
perspective, and this blog
post goes into that
a little bit.
And I don't want to actually
get into YouTube terms of
service and things like that,
but there are penalties in
place if a YouTube account ends
up posting objectionable
slash illegal slash
inappropriate material for
whatever portion of
that there is.
So if you're kind of opening the
door and letting anybody
upload any video into your
account, your own community
might be very--
nobody's out to get you and
nobody has malicious intent,
but anybody else who just
discovers this might say, hey,
wouldn't it be really
funny to upload this
copyrighted music video?
Or hey, somebody in your
community might not realize
that having a music track on
their own video might end up
having some implications from
the terms of service
perspective if they upload it.
So you're really opening
yourself up to some potential
problems if you did have a setup
in which you allowed
people to upload into
your own account.
Furthermore, there are some
quota implications from
allowing a lot of people
to upload videos
into your own accounts.
I don't want to, again, get
into any hard limits or
anything or say what the quota
system specifically is doing,
but one of the things that we
do try to protect against in
the quota system is people
uploading a lot of videos in a
short period of time into
a single account.
So that's not really something
that we want
people to be doing.
And that is the type of setup
that would happen if you just
let any person upload videos
into your account.
Your page gets popular, people
could start uploading into
your account, and all
a sudden, hey,
you've got quota issues.
So the way we recommend working
around that is to
allow users to first
authenticate and authorize
access to your application from
your application to their
own YouTube accounts.
And obviously, anybody who's
been following along knows
that what we recommend using
OAuth 2.0 for that now.
And once you have that Auth
token, you could then allow
users via the API
to upload videos
into their own accounts.
And this works around some of
those policy issues I was
talking about, and this also is
a lot better from a quota
perspective.
You're much less likely to run
into any quota issues.
So there's always a question of,
hey, I want to collect all
these videos in one
place, though.
So if everybody's uploading
videos into their own account,
how do I handle the
moderation step?
Or how do I have feature
certain videos?
And the way to do that,
you could obviously
roll your own solution.
And there's no reason why
you can't just use
the API to do that.
But we do have some
prepackaged open source projects.
And one instance of that is
something called YouTube
Direct Lite.
And that's kind of the new
version of YouTube Direct.
I'm going to plug
it a little bit.
But this supposed to be a quota
talk, so I don't really
want to get too much
into plugging my
own open source projects.
But basically Direct Lite will
provide an easy way for you to
embed and upload widget onto
any arbitrary page, allow
users to authenticate and
to upload into their own
accounts, and then give the
administrator the ability to
take a look at all those videos
that have been uploaded
into each individual account.
And if they like the video,
after they review the video,
they could say, hey, I'd like to
add it to a playlist in my
master account.
And even if you're not using
YouTube Direct Lite, that's
really the model that we think
people should follow where you
use playlists as a way of
curing content that gets
submitted and featuring
what you like.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I have
one question--
JEFF: Sure.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: --if I may.
So one of the ways in which
developers are trying to get
around quotas is by introducing
some level of
caching into their
applications.
Anything in that area that
people should watch out for?
Or any best practices there?
JEFF: Yeah.
Caching is usually something
that is all right to do.
I know that the terms of service
has a few things in
particular that it says about
best practices for caching.
And I don't want to answer
anything too legal or terms of
service-y without
being an expert.
And I don't want to end up
saying something wrong.
So consult the terms of service
if you have any
questions about that.
But, in general, keeping track
of certain pieces of
frequently used data and not
having to query the API every
time you need to make use of
that data, that sounds like a
reasonable approach.
I don't know if there's anything
specific, Jarek, that
you had in mind that you
wanted to cover.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I think,
again, I have the same
concerns as you around trying
to explain the terms of
service, which are pretty
well written and quite
understandable.
But we're not lawyers, although
you seem pretty stiff
on this video, Jeff,
right now.
Yeah, I think the way we phrase
it is that it's fine to
do caching for session
purposes.
And really the common sense
explanation of that is we just
don't want the metadata
to be stale.
Because then, if your
application uses YouTube, then
typically you will make
it known to your user.
And then if somehow the
application, for example,
includes information about the
video that has been removed
and the user tries to access it
then gets upset, then we'll
get some of the blame.
And conversely, when the
application is great, we get
some of the credit,
which we love.
But I think the major concern
there is user experience.
We don't want stale metadata to
be presented to your users,
because then it's a deterrent
to the user experience.
So that's really something
to consider.
If you do cache, I think the
way we phrase in terms of
service, we say it's cool to
do it for session purposes.
But really I think the concept
of a session depends on your
architecture.
But in general, really think
about the user experience.
So metadata can change.
People can make videos private
so you can no longer access
them unless you authenticate
it.
They can change description
and so forth with the API.
Things can get removed
from playlists.
So anything that you do that has
a caching component, make
sure that it does expire within
a reasonable amount of
time so that the user's
experience is not affected.
JEFF: Yeah, absolutely.
There's one other aspect to
quota that I wanted to talk
about before I lose my voice,
and that just has to do with
the fact that there are some
other quota systems that are
in place in addition to the
YouTube data API quota that
you might end up bumping into,
depending on what you're
trying to do.
And I don't necessarily have
too many best practices
recommendations about this,
because they are quota systems
that are separate from what we
normally deal with in the
YouTube data API.
But just knowing about
them might help.
So the Google web
infrastructure, I guess the
YouTube web infrastructure by
extension, does have some kind
of anti-denials of service
protections built into it.
And if you are sending a very
large amount of the HTTP
traffic, whether it's API
requests or any other type of
HTTP traffic, it is possible
to trigger anti-denial of
service protections that
are in place there.
And that again is completely
separate from anything having
to do with the API, and I can't
really say too much
about that other than
it does exist.
And you'll know it because
instead of a normal API
response, you'll get back.
HTML, I think that normally
gets returned.
So it returns a web page telling
you, hey, your traffic
looks a little suspicious
to us.
So keep in mind that
that might happen.
There's also a kind of a
separate, I guess, mini-quota
system that certain YouTube
operations are protected with.
And these operations are
protected with the same
system, whether you're doing
these operations via the API
or via the website.
And specifically commenting and
sending messages to other
YouTube users, there are
limits on the number of
comments you could post in a
given period of time, and
there are limits to the number
messages you can send.
Those limits, like I said, are
not API specific and sometimes
require being cleared by logging
into the website and
solving a CAPTCHA and doing
something like that to prove
that you are a human
and you're not
just sending out spam.
So while that kind of does break
you from the normal API
flow a little bit, and it's a
little unfortunate in that
regard that you might have to
log into the website to clear
that quota issue,
it does exist.
We don't see too
many legitimate
applications run into it.
It's obviously in place to
protect against spammy
applications.
So I think that's the
big book of quota.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
One caveat that I wanted to
add is sometimes we get
inquiries from developers asking
us about CAPTCHA errors
they are facing.
And then we look at the logs
that they supply, and it turns
out that they're actually
scraping the site.
So that's another thing, is if
you actually scrape the site
to obtain some information, and
you get the CAPTCHA, and
this is due to some of the
processes that are shared
across various pieces of our
infrastructure, the solution
to that is simple.
Just use the API, and chances
are you'll be fine, and you
won't be getting that.
So that's another little
behavior that sometimes is
confused for API quotas.
But you're actually not
using the API yet.
So the solution there is use
the API, and I think things
will be better.
So Jeff, anything else
you wanted to cover?
Or should we just transition for
Q&A, since we have a few
more minutes?
JEFF: Yeah.
That ended up taking
quite some time.
And like most topics having to
do with the API, I probably
could have spent another 30
minutes or an hour talking.
But I think transitioning to
something new is probably a
good idea at this point.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
Well, thank you.
So we have a few questions and
just a couple of minutes.
So we'll just go through
them really quickly.
The first question
is about tags.
"YouTube recently made
tags private.
They're still available
in the API.
How should we deal with them?
Remove them as well?
Are there any changes
coming up?"
So yeah, for those of you that
haven't been paying attention,
we did make some changes to
the user experience on the
website and where the
tags are presented.
In the API, what we are planning
to do is really
mirror what the YouTube
functionality provides.
And we will be requiring
authenticated access.
So the owner of the video will
be able to modify and see the
tags, but they will not be
available through the public
access without authentication.
So this is something that we
will introduce to basically
bring the API in line
with what is
currently done on the website.
JEFF: And we'll have a blog post
talking more about that.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
So the second question
is about timeline
for the v3 API rollout.
The developer's not sure how
quickly the code base should
be changed to take advantage
of the new API version.
Jeff, do you want to
take this one?
JEFF: Yeah, again, with my
anti-leak policy, I'm not
going to say that much.
I know that we were a little
opaque about the system for
signing up to the API, and
apologies about that.
We haven't added too many
people to the preview
release right now.
Although Jarek, Jeremy, and I
did spend some time over the
weekend plowing through a little
bit of the backlog.
But basically at this point, we
do have a decent number of
folks who have been testing out
the Version 3 of the API.
We're getting progressively
closer to when we could
actually roll it out
to everybody.
I think it's a matter of months
rather than years or
quarters or anything
like that.
So it should be fairly soon.
And again, folks could play
around with the API using the
web-based API explorer if they
want to just get a preview
feel for how the API is.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Right.
And we did have a product
manager speak about the v3
plans earlier on this show.
So if you look through
the previous
sessions, his name is Vladimir.
Vladimir was actually talking
about that, and I think he
gave some basic parameters with
respect to the rollout.
But we definitely are working on
that hard and looking into
introducing some new
features into that
API to make it enticing.
I think very much we appreciate
your feedback for
those of you that have
been participating
in the Trusted Tester.
If you have a really amazing app
and you just can't wait,
then please let us know, and
we'll try to include you.
Because we want to make sure
that we do a fair amount of
testing with partners before
we roll it out.
It's still going to be in
the experimental phase.
So for production
apps, use v2.
But v3 is going to come with
some really cool features.
Next question is about AdWords
for video, whether the API
will become available.
And I'm not sure about that.
We'll probably have to take
that additional offline
unless, Jeff, you have some
insider knowledge about
AdWords for video API?
JEFF: There's some AdWords folks
standing right outside
my studio now.
And they're about to shoot their
Google Developer Lives,
so I probably could ask them.
But rather than putting them on
the spot, no, I'm going to
have to pass.
And we'll try to follow
up some other time.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: OK.
So the last but not least
question asked by me,
actually, is whether Google or
YouTube Developer relations
are hiring.
Jeremy, what do you think?
JEREMY WALKER: Yes.
Yes, we are hiring.
So you'll want to go to the
Google Developers page.
I think it's under
the Jobs link.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah.
JEREMY WALKER: And we're
hiring not only for the
YouTube team, which we need
somebody, but also across all
the products.
So definitely check
that out if you're
interested and apply.
We'd love to have you.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
Well, I think we're
out of time.
Thank you very much
for watching.
And we'll see you next week.
Next week we will actually
broadcast on Tuesday instead
of Wednesday.
We have a conflict, so watch the
Google Developers G+ page
for the schedule.
JEREMY WALKER: All right.
Thanks.
JEFF: Bye, guys.
[MUSIC PLAYING]